[Musique]
du
non
madame est mon père thomas la mode dans
les eaux
bonjour messieurs dames comment il est
simple et bien manger mieux
alors aujourd'hui en effet on est monté
dans les eaux à la plaine des palmistes
c'est monsieur delattre on va accueillir
du goyavier pour faire des petites
jeunes et à les rives du nil et venez
venez je vous en dis pas plus
venez avec moi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bons amis du village bonjour comment il
est ça va tranquille du peuple au mythe
elle partira ce qui limite l bonne la
seconde il n'y a pas la viellesse et sa
tombe s'il fallait bien alors diamant un
petit peu ou s'annuler est là explique
magicien sanou les coups ça vous fiez
pas à la nous laisser athènes et à nice
aujourd'hui elle est un petit peu de bon
temps la planète il faut ce qu'il faut
voilà nourris sur le verger de la semoy
propriétaire et nous fait la cueillette
de goyave et où beaucoup de monde
proposant un truc sans plus attendre ma
bouche que de l'eau à la bouche et
allons faire voir qu'à des bons à l'eau
[Musique]
à moins qu'ils mangent ali mer rouge
rose en gagnant tout nique chacun à sa
façon de manger
ayem de route est assez les meilleurs
maîtres c'est le verbe sur google alors
diamant un petit peu voilà comment ça se
passe c'est l'exploitation l'ami entendu
moins de travail
voilà ce travail en tant que ça la
finition de la préparation du terrain
pour les gens porter les gens il faut
quand même le terrain les propres de
mantegna mastroianni maintenant votre
boost effet de bout en bout d'un projet
chinois
omar est passé la main millet même ce
que aig ça vous dit moi je connais une
manche à d'exploitation voilà comment
j'aimerais acheter
voilà des mots qui peut le nombre de
temps de travail que nana les
préparations qui peut avoir parce que
les gens me voient goyavier donc son
épouse dans la cour
ce pas un conte avec man soit déchargée
même y pense que quand on a autant de
pieds de goyaviers il faut quand même il
faut quand même du boulot du nettoyage
hysteria et cetera l'ont effectivement
de là commence cette année n'a commencé
depuis janvier dans comment se nettoyer
les terrains alors là nous coupe les
herbes folles apprenons à l'aller
mauvaise hier c'est vrai dans lequel
doit y aviez pourtant rien mais bon
maintenant pour trois mois alors que
l'on entend dénoncer la victoire d ir ou
là pourquoi fini alors si on commence en
janvier
est ce que par exemple outre est est ce
que nantes a une façon particulière que
où arrivent d'autres cours de 9,7 pouces
il pousse naturellement il chargé tant
en ligue 1 dessus on mange mais là où
tous ses pieds la sq ne manque pas son
affaire particulière vraiment naturel
déjà guère 3par après notre non car ici
nous actionnaires naturel ça me met pas
de produit la saga sans nous mettre un
piège pour le moche parce que de la
colonne à gauche défricher la plaine
d'accord donc on va en début de saison
même au niveau des douanes mada pas une
conne à coupler ce diable de mettre pied
ok les barbus comme ça et faire que
non mais traînant à terre au km 11 je
suis venu à l'idée
il permet éviter quand effectivement
qu'on doit y habitons brown un des trois
réacteurs
ouais mais ça c'est vous y avez allions
tous pari pascalien n'étiez pas en
contact qu'un deuxième est en pleine
chaleur au pc est d'accord parfait
beyrouth a lancé une petite visite un
petit peu tous à main est ce qu'on peut
en écrire un petit mot habilité un petit
peu c'est sûr non ben écoute on y va
alors on y va
en partant pour cela le préfet à mon
sens
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tél les oublie les trouve vraiment jolie
voix qui chante ne brouillent aviez les
vraiment magnifique du monde et c'est du
thé ou je me trompe
abbas est dit et rien à voir c'est une
ancienne plantation de thé où on a on a
enlevé et on a mis du goyavier à la
place d'accords et du moi de là je vois
que des petites bouilles habits sont un
petit peu plus petit mbaye et tu peux
mondia prix s'il te plaît bah ouais
après que cette hauteur là mais qui
donne plus il ya plus de feuilles à plus
de café de fouiller dessus parce qu'on
fait c'est qu'on coupe un poids 40 50 cm
du sol et ils vont redonner des
bourgeons 22 3 ans
là on a des pieds qui ont été coupées il
ya trois ans à peu près et voilà ça
redonne des goyaviers sans escale
avantages que c'est c'est que avec les
enfants ils ont la possibilité de cuir
plus facilement des grillages et voilà
parce que précisons toi tu vas pas on à
droite ou à gauche non au contraire moi
c'est des gens qui viennent vers toi
avec un saut qui rentre pour qu'il ya de
tout ce qu'on a voulu faire comme l'an
passé c'est que je revienne dans la
nature ce qui viennent cueillir leurs
fruits c'est vrai qu'on trouve vous
aviez un peu partout sur les marchés
forains
il sert à transformer moi ce que j'ai
voulu faire c'est vraiment ramener les
gens sur la planète à nice les ramener
sur un terrain qui est en toute sécurité
pour qu'ils puissent ramasser voir ce
que c'est que le fruit déguster sur le
fier et voir ce que c'est qu'une
plantation de xavier voilà c'est surtout
ça me troue jo bhi y être je m'attendais
vraiment pas mais aussi de propre carré
gaumont et en diamant avoir de grosses
sommes goyave et sauvage bailly si cela
était planté c'est ici qu'on veut dire
elle avait une plantation de thé ça a
été enlevé on avait dû longueuil dessus
aussi est pleine
plante qui était jeune donc nous a
enlevé et nous l'appelons c'est le
goyavier apprennent à d'autres parcelles
voulait pas planter les aménager mais ça
noah vente à l'heure on va voir après
allez on y va on y va on y va
moi j'utilise du manque toujours un
petit peu juste pour déconner 1
[Musique]
mais quelle diamant petit peu imaginent
mal envie denis avec ma famille un
dimanche après-midi un samedi ou même de
la semaine bien fait rien tout ramasse
goyavier sur scène mais ça veut dire
comment ça se passe d'étudiants venant
le temps utile pour avoir grillé alors
le naira marches rouges bioterra y en a
ils ramassent travers des banques soit
tu le fais avec et les niners beaucoup
et j levier oui mais ça effet papier de
la cueillette sur nous sur saône les
petits sur cinq livres sont sains et
saufs dit d'accord donc alors déjà ces
hausses opa ou kg 70 kg ces eaux sont
maintenant souvenirs mais pas assez dans
mon quartier on avait un python voyage
là et de sud en arrêt brouille avis et
blanc eelv aura un petit goût ya blanc
vous aviez blanc germon town affaires
est remonté nasa va dire mention connaît
ses 19 ans et céline a poussé l'état pur
mais c'est mon fameux xavier blanc et
ben voilà ben moumen 27 ans confie t
elle envie d'une vingtaine de plants se
tirant entre les jambes mais ça on
connaît ils nourrissent un bon moyen
d'accroître leurs oeuvres
voilà donc une âme et ça à mes débuts
j'avais génériques mais n'inquiète pas
afin d'en mesurer de mon métier
ah oui parce qu'ils trouvent que dans le
mode rend moins et malheureusement c'est
le voyage et bougies dans les souliers
rouges
[Musique]
ça saigne son web sont naturels pas de
produits donc moi je vous conseille un
petit truc c'est de venir et de vous
gaver de goyavier ya de la vitamine à
ses très bons on y voit prendre à
défiler en ville et en flore diamant
combien de temps le fruit arrive à une
fois cela il apparaît oui on compte à
peu près trois quatre mois trois quatre
mois il faut vous n'allez plus être
autrement après nagoya dit ça ça va
arriver juifs à jullié n'aura peut-être
pas suffisamment prête à ouvrir pour le
demander
donc ça c'est nous va ramasser nous afin
de confiture avec viens dans mon town un
autre endroit alors montage
[Musique]
donc là qui nous ramène cela passe aussi
été aménagée c'est ça oui c'est qu'on a
fait c'est d'y arriver a dit étaient
présents partout est ce qu'on a fait
c'est qu'on a arraché goyavier à bras
d'homme parce que c'est pas une lancée
par mécanisables donc wade a arraché
pour pouvoir faire les couloirs
circulation pour que les gens puissent
tranquillement c'est gagner sans être
gêné par le club béziers
[Musique]
mais quelle le goyavier est bon dès
qu'on prend sur allart démange
c'est terrible ready mois donne moi un
petit peu les façons de préparer
goyavier s'il-te-plaît les meilleurs
quand je dis aux clients c'est ce qu'ils
font
chacun vit à récolter ses fruits dont
ils font leur jolie leçon leurs
confitures sont leurs roues die qui font
du jus de la glace tout ça en sucre et
de là qui font du caire un sur un canard
par exemple aux vins de grillage il faut
préparer les seclinois bon le petit
magret de canard aux kouriles goya liés
et le poisson grillé avec un quiz à des
fins moi je ressens merritt m'en vais là
j'avais demandé 5 magret de canard
xavier et moi avec goyavier vers le
petit rougail moi petit je me
souviendrai du petit billet vert avec le
seul vrai qu'en ce moment ça coince
piment sec
paris manque carrément assad et ben
voilà on roule à ici après goyavier
c'est autre chose maintenant à l'arrivée
du samu goyavier annoncé quand on est
enfant on a le toit l'air on a dû les
copains que les faits et tout ça et
innove et le bois de goyavier demi
finale
c'est un très bon bois est trop
maintenant nous faut c'est la route se
trouve à pâques et d'affaires étaient
fort boyard michael on est sous le sous
le platane centenaire
je pense qu'il ya plus de 60 ans sur le
faisant du mois qu'à l'idée commence
était venu de dire je vais me lancer
entre guillemets dans goyaviers c'est
mes parents qui ont commencé à à qui ont
mis en place et vergers en l'an 2000
donc ça fait déjà un 17 ans il sait
quand le verger existe mais a décidé de
reprendre l'activité en 2008
d'accord on a pâti passe un diplôme
agricole dans ces petites formes causa
je me suis formé pour le diplôme un des
terrains situés en production fruitière
et aujourd'hui je suis chef
d'exploitation
ben écoute moi j'ai fait une magnifique
visite à j'espère vous aimez redescendre
et bien moi je vais rester encore
l'instant là j'ai apprécié le risque est
ce que toi tu veux rentrer ben oui mais
envoient en effet obligé de partir de
partir c'est comme ça c'est la 17e place
et non je suis pas mais coûte à la
prochaine vraiment mais insistons
accueil assez c'est avec plaisir
ben moi je conseille à tout le monde de
venir bien sûr comme tu disais tout à
l'heure et puis aussi à 7 ce côté marche
que j'aime bien et d'ailleurs bien pour
redescendre
il faut que je marche quelques on a mis
à plus tard les années
au revoir l'ex salut à tort puisque site
du club rappelle bien sûr consommer
local
un bien sûr qu'ils sont poisson local
venez faire un petit tour ici parce que
franchement les goyaviers dont les douze
pareil deniel mal pour nous mesurer les
effets voilà bon bah écoute moi je
redescende en débat il va commencer à
pleuvoir je veux un petit capuche 7
on n'est ce pas une officine gaubert en
tout cas de l'at elle n'est pas levée
mais voilà on n'est pas sorti de
l'auberge
d'accord salut la compagnie à plus tard
[Musique]
il